I’m Jane.
Saving animals takes time,
and we need everyone to help.
Nothing's impossible.
Hold on tight!
Anything’s possible.
Close your eyes and imagine.
Jane Goodall is one of my heroes.
She's such an advocate for all animals.
Every day you live, you make
some impact on the planet.
My mission is to create a
world where we can live in
harmony with nature.
It's very important for children
to know that they themselves
can make a difference.
I wanted to write a positive song.
Every one step, you’re one step closer.
That nothing's impossible.
I like lines like that.
They make you feel like
you could do anything.
There's an animal down there
that needs our help!
[Screaming]
To be able to do this with Diane
was just so special to me.
We're both real animal people.
We love animals, so I'm so happy.
With every one step, you get
closer to your dreams.
It’s not as far as you think.
That was awesome.
This is exactly the kind of message
I want to put out there right now.
The least I can do
is speak out for those
who cannot speak for themselves.
I hope that children will learn
from this show that every single
one of them has a potential
to help save the world.
With every one step, you
get closer to your dreams.
It’s not as far as you think.
Living in harmony with
nature isn't easy, is it?
No, but it's worth it.
You get where you need to go.
Hey, hey!